así es que ahora tenemos esta fracción
dos tercios y los invito a ustedes para
que pausa en el vídeo y piensen en
fracciones que puedan representar el
mismo número que es decir que sean
equivalentes
ok asumiendo que pasaron el vídeo y que
ya pensaron por su cuenta vamos a hacer
lo siguiente tenemos por ejemplo dos
tercios y lo vamos a representar
visualmente
eso implica que yo tendría un
entero
el cual dividir en tres partes iguales
pensemos
que estas son las tres partes iguales
esta fracción nos indica que de esas
tres partes iguales tendremos dos y para
diferenciarlas les voy a marcar con este
aerosol amarillo
lo que tenemos entonces estas dos partes
de las tres partes iguales dibujadas
ahora que tengo este cuadro y que ya lo
hemos dibujado lo voy a copiar y pegar
dos veces para que podamos crear
diferentes fracciones equivalentes
y este es el número 2
si yo quiero hacer una fracción
equivalente lo que veré es que otras
fracciones pueden representar la misma
superficie que tenemos ya marcada en
estos dos tercios si pusiera una línea
horizontal que divida cada una de estas
tres partes en dos partes iguales ahora
cuántas partes tendré tendré una dos
tres cuatro cinco seis
ahora tendré seis posibilidades de las
cuales tendré dibujadas en color
amarillo o coloreadas una dos tres
cuatro
con esto podemos decir que dos tercios
es equivalente a cuatro sextos
lo ven es exactamente la misma
superficie la que hemos manejado
simplemente lo que hicimos fue dividir
cada uno de estos tercios de manera
horizontal y con eso tener seis
posibilidades de espacio de las cuales
cuatro están dibujadas vamos a hacer lo
mismo de este lado pero ahora en vez de
en vez de dividir con una línea
horizontal haremos dos líneas
horizontales
y de esta manera cada uno de esos
tercios estará dividido en tres en
cuántas partes iguales tengo ahora
dividido este rectángulo 123456789 ahora
tenemos nueve posibilidades nueve partes
iguales de las cuales cuántas están
coloreadas o dibujadas en color amarillo
una dos tres cuatro cinco seis tenemos
seis de esas nueve partes con lo que
también podemos decir entonces que seis
novenos es equivalente a dos tercios y a
cuatro sextos cómo funciona esto en una
recta numérica voy a colocar una recta
numérica lo mas derechita que puedan
donde nos enfocaremos del cero
y bueno se puede ir más allá ustedes ya
lo saben vamos a representar cada una de
estas fracciones dentro de nuestra recta
numérica para que veamos si aplica la
equivalencia el primero nos indica que
tenemos dos tercios eso nos dice que del
0 al 1 que será nuestro primer entero
tendremos dividido a nuestra recta
numérica en tres partes iguales
le damos 1
donde nos dice que tenemos dos de esas
terceras partes recorridas así es que
avanzaremos un a
y dos aquí quedará dos voy a cambiar el
color
aquí nos quedará
dos tercios
este será nuestro
marcador vayamos con la siguiente
fracción tenemos 4 sextos este 6 nos
implica que nuestra recta numérica entre
el 0 y el 1 estará dividida en seis
espacios iguales así es que lo colocaré
con anaranjado y dividiremos 12
nuestra fracción
marcada con color anaranjado que dará en
de esas seis partes así es que nos vamos
uno dos tres cuatro justo queda en el
mismo punto donde teníamos los dos
tercios colocaremos aquí cuatro
sextos finalmente nos iremos con esta
fracción seis novenos el nueve implica
que del 0 al 1 hemos dividido en nueve
partes iguales colocaremos eso con otro
color que les parece el azul
entonces si este es un tercio estos son
dos tercios y estos son tres tercios
vamos a dividir en dos cada uno de ellos
tendremos entonces 12
89 hemos dividido del 0 al 1 en nueve
partes iguales como lo indica nuestro
denominador
vamos a contar entonces seis de esas
partes 1 2 3 4 5 6 y efectivamente
volvemos a quedar en la misma posición
de la recta numérica donde teníamos el
dos tercios el 4 sextos y ahora
tendremos 6 novenos con esto podemos
comprobar que dos tercios es una
fracción equivalente a cuatro sextos y
seis novenos nos vemos en otro vídeo